salut la team quant à l'eau quand je
rencontre quelqu'un et que je lui
explique que je fais une vidéo par jour
pendant un an la première question
qu'ils me pose c'est donc pas vraiment
que ça à [ __ ] non ça c'est ce qu'il
pense mais la question c'est t'as pas
peur de tomber en panne d'inspiration et
bien non alors je suis pas plus créatif
que vous à la base mais la créativité ça
s'apprend et aujourd'hui je vais vous
donner les techniques que j'utilisais
que vous allez aussi pouvoir utiliser
premièrement donnez un bon gros coup de
pied dans la fourmilière la routine ça
empêche l'innovation alors je dis pas
qu'en cassant les habitudes vous allez
avoir tout de suite instantanément des
éclairs de génie mais ça va vous ouvrir
à d'autres choses
vous pouvez aller dans des endroits
complètement improbable réponse vous
pouvez faire du covoiturage vous pouvez
prendre un autre chemin que celui de
d'habitude pour aller à l'école ou à
votre travail du matin vous pouvez
ranger votre maison votre chambre bureau
complètement différemment en regardant
dans un petit peu tout pouvez aussi
aller voir un spectacle que vous n'iriez
pas voir du tout à la base même de
l'opéra ou de la danse ou un spectacle
comique qui vous concernent pas
habituellement que vous cherchiez à être
plus créatifs dans ma vie
professionnelle personnelle culturel
artistique peu importe vous allez vous
ouvrira d'autres pensées vous n'auriez
pas eu dans votre routine et votre train
train habituel pour ça à chaque fois que
vous casser la routine fait une espèce
d'autoanalyse parlez vous avoue même
tiens qu'est-ce que je peux retirer de
sa caisse l'idée ça m'amènerait comment
je pourrais en bénéficier comment je
pourrais m'en servir deuxième technique
soyez un enfant fait quand même quand on
est petit on se pose pas la question se
juge pas honte est plein de choses on
teste plein d'idées sans se juger sur le
résultat de l'idée en elle même au lieu
d'écrire sur une feuille de papier
destiné à la place quand vous avez un
problème faisant un jeu c'est à dire
trouver des règles vraiment des
objectifs jouer avec ce problème la
posez vous des questions complètement
décalé sur ce que vous avez à faire pour
avoir un angle de vue complètement
indifférent troisième technique que
j'utilise beaucoup c'est changer l'ordre
des choses en ce moment chez entend
décrire mon nouveau spectacle dans les
prochaine et je travaille pas du tout du
début du spectacle jusqu'à la fin du
spectacle en fait je travaille sur plein
de choses en même temps et même danser
plein de choses je les fais pas
forcément dans lord j'écris des petits
bouts un petit peu partout sans
forcément les finir chaque idée est
développée individuellement à des fois
ça m'emmène ouvert d'autres choses et
l'emballage la finalité ça je la verrai
plus tard à la fin
catherine technique et un peu la reine
des techniques dont on parle en
créativité mais qui est vraiment
efficace et le brainstorming générer des
idées aléatoirement vous écrivez un mot
sur une feuille décrivez votre mot et
ensuite vous écrivez 5
o qui vous font penser à ce moment là
par exemple si j'écris spectacle ici je
vais peut-être écrire public je vais
peut-être écrire théâtre je vais écrire
comme ça cinq mots qui me font penser à
ce mot là et ensuite vous allez écrire
cinq mots aux cinq mots que vous avez
déjà écrit donc 25 mo de plus et les
cinq mois à chaque fois en rapport avec
le mot par exemple le public je vais
écrire cinq mots en lien avec le public
et pour terminer vous prenez deux des 25
mots que vous avez écrit vous avez
essayé de les associer ensemble des fois
il va rien se passer
souvent il va rien se passer même mais
des fois ça va vous faire une connexion
que vous n'auriez pas eu à la base et ça
va vous donner l'idée du siècle 5e
technique ma préféré utiliser des my
maps la carte mentale
alors c'est un petit peu comme le
brainstorming mais en beaucoup moins
aléatoire j'ai d'ailleurs fait déjà une
vidéo dessus que je vais vous mettre ici
en lien dans le descriptif
me concernant c'est l'outil le plus
puissant que je peux utiliser aussi bien
pour la mémoire que pour la créativité
je vais pas complètement le détail et
puisque j'ai déjà fait la vidéo là
dessus mais disons que pour un exemple
concret si vous recherchez un
appartement vous écrivez appartement
avec une bulle entouré et là je vais
commencer à faire des connexions et dans
chacune de ces connexions de ces bulles
là je mette une technique pour trouver
un appartement agences immobilières
chasseur d'appartement petites annonces
réseaux sociaux application sur le
téléphone portable émission de
télévision pourquoi pas et ensuite pour
chacune de ces bulles là que j'aurais
fait je vais écrire les avantages et les
inconvénients et peut-être aussi le
moyen de les contacter bref je me faire
une carte comme ça de toutes ses
possibilités et à la fin peu importe
pourquoi vous faites ce travail là vous
allez avoir une vision très claire de
tous les chemins possibles
très pratique la créativité c'est ni
plus ni moins le jeu de mario bros et
alors il faut savoir tomber et se
vautrer un petit peu pour pouvoir aller
de plus en plus loin donc en face de
créativité ne vous jugez pas à aucun
moment on ne pensait pas encore en
résultat final c'est beaucoup trop tôt
pour le faire ne vous censurez pas
essayer tenez et laissez vous aller
j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo elle
vous aidera aujourd'hui ou même dans le
futur si vous vous utilisez d'autres
techniques de créativité vous les
trouvez intéressants n'hésitez pas à les
mettre dans les commentaires pour en
faire bénéficier tout le monde toute la
team menthe à l'eau pour info j'ai un
tout petit peu de retard demain je ferai
la vidéo du tirage au sort du concours
qu'on a fait la semaine dernière et je
vous mettrais un lien dans la vidéo de
demain pour aller voir les résultats du
concours faites preuve d'une magnifique
créativité artistique en laissant un
pouce en l'air cette vidéo n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner avant de
non c'est par la wii de vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental veut
que c'est une vidéo par jour durant
toute une année donc rendez vous demain
à 17h chao je joue mon spectacle en
entier le 23 septembre à la garenne
colombes c'est la date la plus proche de
paris si jamais vous voulez venir sinon
il ya toutes les dates de tournée sur
mon site